well the consequences of the war after
one week are staggering death and
destruction on the ground in ukraine a
massive exodus of refugees as we've just
been hearing scenes of fierce resistance
from ukrainian soldiers and ordinary
people as well and a president who's
rallied much of the world around his
cause
meanwhile russia has become increasingly
isolated and its economy is in free fall
let's take a closer look back now at the
events of the past week
it started with a speech
russian president vladimir putin
announced a special military operation
in ukraine he said he would demilitarize
and denazify the country
and an all-out assault on ukraine
started
[Music]
people took refuge wherever they could
like here in kiev's subway stations
while the bombardments above grew more
intense
across the country
this is the result of relentless
airstrikes and rounds of shelling
of thousands of people have fled ukraine
what the un refugee agency is calling
europe's greatest refugee crisis this
century
heading to neighboring countries
they're mainly women and children
to save
my life life of my baby
and my husband's life
bombing well for the first time i saw a
field strewn with missiles and a forest
that is just raised to the ground
all night long we have had planes flying
all the time air raid alarms
ukraine i will not say more glory to
ukraine glory to the heroes
ukrainians have put up a stiff fight
both sides have incurred heavy losses
russian morale is reported to be low and
some forces are reported to have
surrendered or sabotaged their own
vehicles
meanwhile ukraine's president vladimir
zelansky refused to leave the capital
when the u.s offered him safe passage
out he said he needed ammunition not a
ride
he spoke movingly to western leaders
we are fighting for our rights for our
freedoms for life for our life
and now we are fighting for survival and
this is the highest motivation
but we are also fighting to be equal
members of europe
so prove that you are with us prove that
you will not let us go
prove that you are indeed europeans and
then life will win over death and light
will win over darkness glory be to
ukraine
europe and the us have responded with
crushing sanctions on russia cutting off
its banks from much of the world
regulators closed the stock market to
stop panic selling russians lined up at
cash machines afraid the economy would
go into free fall
as the sanctions piled up putin put his
nuclear forces on high alert and
escalated bombardments
a week into the war an armored convoy
more than 60 kilometers long is moving
slowly toward kiev
hundreds of tanks artillery and
personnel carriers
for those still in the city the fight
may have just begun and the worst may be
yet to come
we're going across now to ed arnold he's
a research fellow for european security
at the russia defense and security think
tank in london
ed when you look at this war what are
some of the things that stand out to you
from a security perspective
so i think the first thing is the
preparation on the the russian side has
been very poor uh it's worth noting that
since 2008 and when the russians were
um a military offensive in georgia there
was a sweeping russian modernization of
its forces um so we were expecting the
russians to fight
far better than they have
thus far
um i think key to that has been poor
political and military leadership and
ultimately that the soldiers on the
ground were not actually told much about
the operation and the scale of it until
the 11th hour just before they invaded
last thursday um
in contrast to that the ukrainian
wilter fight has been exemplary their
moral components in terms of their
leadership and morale has been excellent
and actually has been decisive in the
initial stages of this war um but now
we're moving to a
more difficult stage for the ukrainian
armed forces
um this week your think tank published
an article warning a frustrated putin is
a dangerous one what do you mean by that
and are we seeing signs of frustration
from the russian president
yes i believe so i mean that this
operation has not gone according to plan
uh from putin i think it was very
difficult for the military to turn his
political objectives into realistic
military objectives
they made assumptions about the
ukrainian will to fight and also
assumptions about how quickly they would
be able to take kiev and remove
president zielenski and probably put
in um a government that was more
sympathetic to moscow and that's had
real consequences the fact that they
were not able to do it so quickly has
caused
other issues
and really now they have
tried to move to
actually fight how the russian way of
warfare suggests which is the heavy use
of
artillery the heavy use of their power
use of overwhelming force i don't think
they went there initially because they
wanted to limit
civilian casualties and uh destruction
of critical national infrastructure
because they wanted
a new government to be able to govern
the country so the more indiscriminate
the attacks and the more brutal the
fighting gets for the key population
centers there's actually more
less favorable political options or
putin so there's a bit of an issue here
with timing that the russians need
to secure objectives very quickly to
prevent the lowering of even already low
morale
but this takes time and they're taking
far heavier casualties than they thought
they ever would
what about further escalation uh how
concerned are people in in your field
for example about the threat of nuclear
war
the thing the first point to note is
that this is not a nuclear crisis
i believe that the
nuclear posturing on the on the russian
side is very much to do with
you know
trying to warn nato off um
further
escalation and further support to
ukraine so i think the first point to
know this is not a nuclear crisis
however this is uh um
a situation that could escalate further
very quickly so for example
um nato is supplying lethal aid uh nato
country sorry is supplying lethal aid to
ukraine
um
you know it it's not inconceivable to
come up with some certain scenarios that
actually puts russian forces and nato
forces very close together um and then
that that could escalate in in a number
of ways so it's so the the risk is there
and i think planners on the western side
are taking that very seriously
uh and an escalation could also is also
linked to the the calls for a no-fly
zone there have been many calls for a
no-flying zone over ukraine including
including from ukrainian president
zelinski himself many on the other side
saying that's not a good idea explain to
us why that wouldn't be a good idea
i think it just makes the risk of
escalation even greater i mean that
there are multiple ways of enforcing a
no-fly zone in terms of what's allowed
in and what's not and whether certain
aircraft are allowed in or it's just a
blanket
ban on or on the air space but
essentially would mean that whoever was
enforcing the no-fly zone would have to
potentially suppress their defense
assets which are located in russia uh
and belarus
to in order to protect the
their own uh personnel uh and fighter
pilots so it's it's it's tantamount to
really declaring war on russia and one
very recent example
unfortunately yesterday a romanian
mig-21 went down over the black sea and
also the search and rescue helicopter
that went to retrieve the pilot also
went down due to weather
however it's a it's it's a it's an event
unfortunately that just shows how
escalation could occur because you need
to verify the information and verify how
it went down of course romania is a nato
member so i think enforcing the no-fly
zone is just a significant escalation
and i just don't think it'd practically
work uh over ukraine at the moment
ed thanks very much for breaking that
down for us ed arnold european security
analyst at the russia defense think tank
the united nations general assembly has
adopted a resolution demanding russia
immediately stops using force against
ukraine and withdraws its military from
the country the historic non-binding
resolution was backed by
141 out of
193 member states with only five
countries voting against before the vote
ukraine's ambassador to the un accused
russia of seeking to commit genocide in
his country and called on the world to
stand together against moscow's
aggression
here's u.n secretary general antonio
guterres speaking after the vote
the general assembly has spoken
as secretary general it is my duty to
stand by this resolution
and be guided by its call
the message of the general assembly is
loud and clear
and hostilities in ukraine now
silence the guns now
open the door to dialogue and diplomacy
now
the territorial integrity and
sovereignty of ukraine
must be respected in line with u.n
charter
we don't have a moment to lose
the brutal effects of the conflict are
plain to see
but as bad as the situation is for the
people in ukraine right now
it threatens to get much much worse
the ticking clock
is a time bomb
looking ahead
i will continue to do everything in my
power to contribute to an immediate
cessation of hostilities and urgent
negotiations for peace
people in ukraine
desperately
need peace
and people around the world
demand it
let's get more from dw political
correspondent julia saldelli julia this
resolution is non-binding so can it
really make any difference well if we
expect russia to now suddenly stop the
war because of this resolution that is
not going to happen even though the
resolution says they should immediately
withdraw their two troops from ukraine
putin is not going to do that just
because the u.n general assembly decided
that but nonetheless it is a strong
signal and especially it's
rare it doesn't really happen that often
that the security council convenes the
general assembly to vote on such a
resolution the last time it happened was
in 1982 so that is already a signal of
the importance of uh this vote and also
we've seen that ukraine has garnered
quite a bit of support
from the majority of of members of the
general assembly
and also some countries that
traditionally might support
russia have abstained from the vote so
on the one hand it's not legally binding
but it puts pressure on russia and shows
that the international community is
strongly behind ukraine and it also is a
diplomatic victory for ukraine and also
if we look at the vote in the security
council earlier
sure russia has a right to veto so
russia vetoed a resolution condemning
the war but out of 15 members 11 voted
in favor of the resolution and three uh
abstained so overall quite a strong
signal in support of ukraine you touched
on it there but tell us a little bit
more about those traditional friends of
russia who voted uh against including
cuba and serbia for example
yes these are countries that are
traditionally close uh with russia and
uh it was expected that they would
support russia but what we've seen is
that actually they didn't vote um with
russia so against the rebel resolution
but
they abstained
now that um
shows that some of these countries are
in a tricky situation russia had even
put forward a diplomatic effort to try
to
close in ties with these countries and
try to get them even more on that side
it sent some officials for example to
cuba to talk to
members of the government there
but cuba did end up abstaining and that
is because cuba is walking a fine line
on the one hand they haven't fully
endorsed russia they also haven't openly
condemned
its actions and
the non-endorsement it's also because
cuba is nervous about what its trade
partners for example in europe might do
if uh it goes clearly with russia but
then we have the case of south africa
which also abstained and that was maybe
a bit of a surprise for for some and
south africa has put out a statement
explaining their uh their vote saying
that they find that the resolution
itself
does not create the right environment
for diplomacy to take place and that the
u.n should push for diplomacy in the
first place and that they also find that
the resolution does not address the
security concerns that russia has so in
some way sort of giving credit to what
russia has been seeing in the last few
weeks
you talk about that diplomacy that all
important word here i mean what does
this mean if it doesn't have any
real-life implications and it's not
going to you know cause russia to
withdraw what does it mean
diplomatically for them it certainly
shows that russia is isolated right now
of the few countries that openly
voted against the resolution are
themselves considered also pariah states
i mean it was russia itself belarus
syria north korea
and
clearly you know the international
community is not standing with russia
right now but that does not mean that
the west is now just going to close all
ways of dialogue with russia
there is still hope that talking to
russia might bring the country to stop
the war that's something that also
german chancellor olaf schultz said
yesterday it's now time to give
diplomacy a chance and
hope that dialogue can bring this
conflict to an end quickly even though
it wasn't really good at preventing that
conflict in the first place yeah all
right julia sardeli thanks very much for
explaining that for us
well here are some more headlines from
this war hundreds of ukrainian civilians
have blocked streets to stop russian
troops reaching europe's largest nuclear
power plant a video on social media
shows civilian-built roadblocks around
the plant in the southeast ukrainian
town of inner hotdog
russia claimed this week to have taken
the town ukraine ukraine denies this
police in moscow have detained a group
of children for laying flowers at the
ukrainian embassy according to a social
media user some were as young as seven
people were also arrested in petersburg
a monitoring group says more than 8 000
anti-war protesters have been detained
in the past week
more than 40 000 people gathered in the
german city of munich on wednesday to
protest the war the crowd was 10 times
larger than organizers had anticipated
and one of the biggest demonstrations
the city has seen in years
you